The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: And
so on today's hand out
we're continuing to
think about color.
We're also going to think
about magnetism some more,
and we're going to think about
more types of geometries.
So we've seen that the type
of ligand, whether it's
a weak field, intermediate
field, or strong field ligand
makes a difference in terms
of the splitting energy.
How much the d
orbitals are split due
in the presence of
the ligand, arranged
in octahedron geometry.
But we'll see that
the geometry matters.
That if you have different
kinds of geometries, then
the splinting is
going to be different
between the d orbitals.
So now we're going to
look-- and I'll set this up.
We're going to look at
a nickel demo, which
we'll have in a few minutes.
But first, let's think about the
colors that we're going to see.
So if we have a nickel chloride
compound that is greenish,
what kind-- it will absorb
then what kind of light,
if it is a greenish
kind of color?
What color would it absorb then?
AUDIENCE: Red.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Red.
Reddish, which is what
kind of wavelength?
Long or short?
AUDIENCE: Long.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Long.
Right.
So we're going to get a
long, reddish kind of-- it
will absorb a long
or red wavelength.
And so if we're absorbing
a long wavelength, what
would be true about
the splitting energies?
Is it going to be a big
or small splitting energy?
So first, if you
have long wavelength
what's the frequency?
Long or short?
AUDIENCE: Short.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Short.
And so the energy
would be short as well.
So it's going to be a small
energy associated with it.
Just a small splitting.
And you remember what we
learned about chloride minus?
What kind of a ligand is it?
It's a weak field ligand,
so this makes sense.
So a weak field ligand only
splits the field a little bit,
it's not a very strong
ligand, so it can only
split it so much.
Now we're going to take
this greenish compound
and we're going to
add some water to it.
And that's going to make
it a little more blue.
Be sort of a blue green.
And let's think about
what's happening there.
And we'll compare it
to what we have above.
So now, if it looks blue
green, what sort of color
is going to be what's absorbed?
AUDIENCE: Orange red.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Right.
So we're going to have a
more orange red color here.
And so that's going to be longer
or shorter than the one above?
AUDIENCE: Shorter.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Shorter.
Right.
So we were here.
Now we're moving more
into the orange region,
so we're going to be
absorbing a wavelength that's
a bit shorter.
So is the energy going
to be larger or smaller?
Yeah.
So it's going to be a
larger energy because we
have a shorter
wavelength so we're
going to have a bit
of a higher frequency.
And so we'll have a higher
energy or larger energy.
And do you remember what
kind of ligand water is?
It's an intermediate
field ligand
so it's going to be
stronger than chloride.
So chloride was very weak.
Water sort of in the middle.
And then we had cyanide as an
example of a very strong field
ligand.
So this makes sense that
would be a bit stronger.
So we have a larger splitting.
Now they're going to break
this sample into two.
And batch one you're
going to add EDTA.
That was our chelating agent
that we talked about before,
and that's going to make
it even a bit more blue.
And here we have our model
of EDTA bound to our metal.
And so if we think
about this, then
if it's a bit more
blue-- so we're
going to be absorbing a color
that's even more orange.
And so that's going to be even
shorter than what we had there.
So then our splitting energy--
the energy is going to be what?
Larger or smaller?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yeah.
So it will be even larger.
And I've never told you
what kind of ligand EDTA is,
but from this, if you're
getting a larger splitting,
you would predict it's a
stronger ligand than water.
And in fact it is an even
stronger one than water.
And again, we're going to be
increasing entropy in this room
in a few minutes
because we're going
to be displacing six
water molecules with one
molecule of EDTA, which
will bind to your metal
with six points of attachment.
So watch out for
that entropy change.
So that was batch one.
Now we're going to take some of
this nickel hexa-aquo compound
and we're going to mix it
with another chelating agent.
So remember, our nickel
water complex is blue green
and we're going to add
another chelating agent,
and now it's going
to become red.
And so if it's red, what
color is going to be absorbed?
AUDIENCE: Green.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Green.
And so this wavelength
then is going
to be what compared to orange?
Yeah, so it's even way shorter.
We were kind of right up here.
Now we've all the way shifted
down here so it's way shorter.
So the energy is
going to be what?
Small or big?
AUDIENCE: Big.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: It's
going to be very big.
But this isn't an
octahedral system anymore,
so I didn't have a
little O by my energy.
And it's actually a
square planar system
so we're not gonna do sort
of a direct comparison here.
But this tells us
that in square planar
you're probably going to
get pretty big splitting
of our d orbital energies
because we can get something
that-- the color suggests that
there must be a big splitting.
So those are what we're
predicting for the colors.
Let's see what happens.
GUEST SPEAKER: Is it on?
Yes it is.
OK.
So this is the nickel
chloride complex
that Cathy was talking about.
As most of us can
see it's very green.
Put it under here.
You could probably obviously
see that it's green.
Maybe against this background.
Look at that.
It's very green.
Thank you, Elena.
So we don't need that, do we?
No, we don't need that.
We're just gonna pour
it into the water.
So when we pour this
into the water we're
expecting-- you guys remember?
Blue green.
So [INAUDIBLE].
And that's fuming.
That smells.
Terrible.
And that's very
obviously not that clear.
[LAUGHTER]
Wonderful.
Well, it's kind of blue green.
Right around the color that
you'd expect for water to be.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: We
should switch gloves
from green to blue green
as we do the experiment.
You can see it a little
bit better there maybe.
I don't know.
Trust us.
GUEST SPEAKER: Now
we're going to do--
CATHERINE DRENNAN: The next
one's a little more dramatic.
Front row.
Is it blue green?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER: So we're
going to split this up
into two solutions,
which is about 180 mls.
I should have picked a
different colored glove.
And we're going to add
some EDTA-- thank you.
We're going to add
some EDTA into this.
And that EDTA is where?
It's a powder, right?
So EDTA is relatively
insoluble in water
so we're going to add
a little bit of base
to make sure this works.
That's not the base.
That's the base.
So let's start with the EDTA.
I'm gonna use this
to mix, I think.
I should mix it with this.
I should have gotten
something to mix it with.
I don't think so.
Watch out.
This is going to
be a bit reactive.
It worked pretty well, actually.
Look at that.
Yay.
It's blue.
Just a second.
[LAUGHTER]
So by comparison it's
a little bit more blue.
And as we added some
hydroxide-- or not hydroxide,
acetate-- it allowed the EDTA
to dissolve just a little bit
more, which is why it reacted.
OK, cool.
So now for the last thing we
will add-- what are we adding?
Oh, right.
DMG.
And we apologize to Cathy
because this smells really,
really bad and she has to smell
this for the next 20 minutes
along with the front row.
AUDIENCE: So will the front row.
GUEST SPEAKER: Sorry.
But after we pour this
you're not actually
going to see a whole
lot of color change.
It smell bad.
And the reason for that
is because this is not
quite as good.
So the DMG has to come in and
actually replace the water,
and it's actually kind of
hard for DMG to replace water.
So what we're going
to do now is we're
going to add a bit of ammonia.
And the ammonia can
replace the water
a little better
than the DMG can,
and the DMG is going
to replace the ammonia.
And you'll see
something kind of cool.
It's actually going to
very locally change color,
and I might actually do this.
Maybe over here.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: What to
do it on the document camera?
GUEST SPEAKER: Is going
to work on the camera?
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Mhm.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
And let's give this a shot.
Well, I can't reach that.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: You
have to move your hand.
GUEST SPEAKER: Let me pour it.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yeah, so
you can see the local now.
GUEST SPEAKER: So it goes
back to being blue green again
because the concentration
of ammonia that we're adding
is not quite enough to
counteract the amount of water
that's already in here.
But if we add enough eventually
it will turn totally red.
But for it now you can see it's
an equilibrium reaction, yay.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: And it talks
about also rates of reactions
and rates of exchange,
and that's our next unit.
[LAUGHTER]
GUEST SPEAKER: Yay.
[CLASS OOHS]
GUEST SPEAKER: Aw.
Well, that's a good lead
in to the next demo, right?
CATHERINE DRENNAN: All right.
Thank you guys.
So you saw that
red color develop,
and so it's not just
about whether something is
a strong or weak field ligand.
It's also about the geometry.
So we're going to talk later
about square planar geometry,
so keep in mind that
we'd expect that there
should be some splitting
between those d orbitals.
But before we get
to square planar
we're going to do tetrahedral.
So here is our
tetrahedral system.
Here's my little
drawing of tetrahedral,
and I have my
tetrahedral model here.
And so here we're going to
have our tetrahedral coordinate
frame like this, where
we have two ligands
in the plane of the screen.
One ligand coming out at you
and one ligand going back.
And so now we're going
to think about how
our different sets of d orbitals
are going to be affected
by tetrahedral geometry.
And again, remember crystal
field theory is just
saying that the ligands are
like negative charges pointing
toward the d orbitals.
So when the ligand
and the d orbital
are near each other--
big repulsion.
When they're farther
away-- less repulsion.
So let's look at this case now.
And so here we see
in this geometry
our ligands are now off axis.
Here is the z-axis.
Here's the y-axis.
Here is the x-axis.
Our ligands are off axis.
So our orbital sets that
are also kind of off axis
are going to be more affected
than our orbital sets that
were on axis.
So this is different
from what we saw
with the octahedral geometry.
So now we have more repulsion
between those negative point
charges that are the ligands
and the d orbitals that
are off axis.
The ones that are
45 degrees away.
So our dyz, dzy, and dxz.
So this is, in
fact, the opposite
of the octahedral case
because in the octahedral case
we had-- the
ligands were on axis
and so the orbitals that were
on axes were the most affected.
But now with tetrahedral
ligand's off axis so
the orbitals that are off
axis are the most effective.
So these switch positions now.
And dx squared minus
y squared dz squared.
They still have the same energy.
They're still degenerate
with respect to each other,
but now these are stabilized
compared to these.
But they also have
the same energy.
So all of these
three orbital sets
are also at the same energy.
Also degenerate.
Now, one other really important
thing about tetrahedral
is not only is it the opposite
of octahedral in terms
of where those orbitals
are, but overall they're
sort of less splitting.
So even though the orbitals
that are kind of off axis
are more affected by
that tetrahedral geometry
than the others,
still the ligands
aren't really pointing right
toward those orbitals at all.
They're closer but
they're not right at them.
So it's very different
from the octahedral case
where you had the orbitals
sort of right on axis
and the ligands right on axis.
So there's less splitting.
It's smaller splitting.
So the octahedral, or the
tetrahedral crystal field
splitting energy,
is this delta sub t.
And that's going to be smaller.
So let's look now at some
crystal field splitting
diagrams.
I'm going to compare
the octahedral case
with the tetrahedral case.
So here is our
octahedral case again.
We have our octahedral crystal
field splitting energy--
our delta O. Now we have our
tetrahedral crystal field
splitting energy-- delta t.
And we see again that
it's opposite orders.
So our dx squared
minus y squared
dz squared, instead of being up
here as it is with octahedral,
is now down here.
And instead of our EG
we now just have E.
We just lost the G here.
And our three sets that
were stabilized, compared
to the hypothetical
spherical crystal field,
are now de-stabilized because
those orbitals at 45 degrees
are closer to our
tetrahedral ligands.
So again, we have this switch.
And again, our EG goes to just
G. The book sometimes has E2.
I don't know where that came
from but you should just
ignore it.
It's just E. And T2G
is now is just T2.
So again, you can
see in this picture
really well-- splitting energy
is a lot less for tetrahedral.
This is much smaller than
the octahedral crystal field
splitting energy, so much,
much smaller because again,
none of those
ligand point charges
are really directly
toward those orbitals.
So overall, it's less splitting.
And because there's
less splitting, when
you think about putting
electrons in to the system
it doesn't take
much to go up here.
So the pairing energies
is going to always
be a lot greater than the energy
to put it in this higher energy
orbital set because
it's not very much
higher than the first set.
So these would all
be high spin systems.
So we put in our
electrons singly
to the fullest extent possible
before we start to pair them.
So you can assume that
all tetrahedral complexes
are high spins.
That's a pretty good assumption.
So just like the
tetrahedral case,
we have overall--
we're maintaining
the energy of the system.
So in the tetrahedral
case we had three orbitals
that were stabilized.
So they went down by
2/5 and two that went up
were de-stabilized,
so they went up
by 3/5 to maintain the
overall energy of the system.
In the tetrahedral case
we have two orbitals
that are stabilized
down in energy,
so they're down by minus 3/5.
And then we have three up,
so those are up by 2/5.
So same idea, but again,
everything is opposite.
So let's take a
look at an example
of the tetrahedral case, and
we'll look at chromium 3 plus.
So what is the d count here?
Who can just tell me?
Find chromium in our table.
Yup.
It's going to be three,
so group 6 minus 3 is 3.
And now, why don't
you tell me how
we are going to put in
those three electrons?
All right.
10 more seconds.
OK.
Most people got that right.
So again, this is not correct
for a high spin, which
most tetrahedral compounds are.
This would be correct.
This arrangement of
electrons is also correct,
but if you look at the orbital
names those are incorrect.
So on a test you need
to be able to write
all the correct orbital names
and the correct designators
as well, as well as
putting it in the electrons
in the right way.
So good to practice.
So we put in now our
three electrons over here,
and now we can think about
our dn configuration.
So if you're asked to
write out the d to the n
electron configuration,
what that's asking you for
is to say how many electrons
are in which of the two
orbital levels.
And so you would say, in the
e level here you have two
and in the t2
level you have one.
And this is just
then a shorthand.
That's why they have these
little abbreviations.
You don't have to write out all
the names of your d orbitals.
So how many unpaired
electrons do we have then?
We have what?
Three.
And if I'm now telling you that
this is a complex with chloride
and that the wavelength of the
most intensely absorbed light
is 740, why don't
you predict the color
of the complex for me?
OK.
10 more seconds.
Yup.
So we can look and
see this wavelength
is going to be in the red
so that the predictive color
of the complex would be the
complimentary, or green.
And so green then is one
that has-- it's pretty short.
This is a pretty
long wavelength,
which would be consistent with
a very tiny splitting energy.
So now let's think about
the square planar case.
So our square planar
system is described--
so we're in the plane here.
It's, again, square planar.
And now we have our
ligands along the y-axis
and the x-axis.
So we have nothing
along the z-axis here.
So tell me, based on this
and then again our ligands
are on axis, which
of those d orbitals
do you think is
going to be the most
de-stabilized by this geometry?
What do you think?
You can just yell it out.
AUDIENCE: x squared
minus y squared.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: x
squared minus y squared.
And what would you think
would be next in terms
of de-stabilized of those sets?
xy?
Yeah, so that's the case.
So most is going to be dx
squared minus y squared.
Again, those
orbitals are on axes.
ligands on axis.
Next would be the other
one that has x and y.
So let's take a
look at this now.
So we have our dx
squared minus y squared.
Our orbitals are on axis.
Our ligands are on axis.
You really have
lots of repulsion.
So this would be de-stabilized
the most compared
to all other d orbitals.
Really different amount
of destabilization.
This is a lot of repulsion.
All the ligands are right
toward those orbitals.
So dz squared, which
used to be degenerate
with dx squared minus y
squared now is not anymore.
There's a lot less
repulsion for this
because there's no ligands
along the z-axis anymore.
So let's look at our
other orbital set.
The next one in terms of
being de-stabilized is dxy.
Now, these orbitals are off axis
so it's not nearly as bad as
for dx squared minus y squared.
But compared to
everything else it's
a lot more repulsion
than everybody else,
but it's less than our dx
squared minus y squared.
And these guys are then
going to be stabilized
compared to the others.
So let's now draw our
splitting diagrams
and think about how this
all plays in together.
And so again, we'll compare
it to our octahedral crystal
field.
So now, the most de-stabilized
way up here, which
is this orbital going to be?
Which one?
x squared minus y squared.
Right.
That's up in energy the
most, so most de-stabilized.
It's experiencing
the most repulsion.
And then next, but
much lower down, dxy.
Again, the ligands are
along in the xy plane,
so that would be second.
But those are 45 degrees off
axis so it's way down in energy
compared to the ones
that are on axis.
And then down here we
kind of have all the rest,
and it's usually written
with dz squared here
and then dyz and dxz over here.
But the order here--
these are all kind of
stabilized compared to these
two and the exact order
is not quite as firm as in
octahedral or tetrahedral
cases.
So again, this is
quite different now.
Overall, the energy
is also maintained,
but there's too many
orbitals in too many places
so you're not
expected to know that.
But one thing that
I will point out
is that remember for
the demo square planar--
we said that had to have
a pretty big splitting?
That's a really big splitting
of the energy of the orbital.
So square planar
complexes can be
capable of having
big energies-- you
need a big energy
of your photon to be
absorbed by a square planar.
Or you could if you're going to
bump it all the way up there.
That's really far away.
So now, clicker.
Why don't you tell
me what you think
of a square pyramidal case?
And this would be this case
here where you have one ligand.
You have a square planar
geometry, basically,
that you've added
an extra ligand too.
Or you had octahedral
you took one away,
and that extra ligand
is along the z-axis.
So what things do you
think would be true?
Since we're running
out of time let's
just take 10 more seconds.
So just to put--
that would be true.
Now there's a ligand
along z, so dz squared
is going to be de-stabilized
in the square pyramidal case
compared to the square planar.
Everything that has z's in it
would also be de-stabilized,
and these would definitely
not be degenerate.
There's no reason they would
have the same energy there.
So we'll get to our
bio example on Monday,
but first what are the results?
[CHEERING]
Awesome.
Congratulations.
That was unexpected.
Two new groups.
All right.
Have a good weekend.
See you Monday.
So end of lecture 29 last page.
We were talking about
biological examples.
transition metals.
We're talking about
colors of things.
And I just wanted to give
you an example of why
geometry can matter
or be interesting
from a biological context.
So the video that you
heard about nickel
showed that nickel
allows H.pylori
to colonize your stomach because
the nickel enzyme creates
a buffering system so
that it can survive
in the low pH of your stomach.
And it's very hard to
treat H.pylori infections
because the antibiotics
that you would
give to kill the
bacteria get destroyed
in acidity of the stomach,
so it's a very hard problem.
And it's fascinating that they
can use this nickel enzyme
to kind of allow themselves
to live in this environment,
so that's pretty cool.
This is also really
cool and arguably more
beneficial to mankind.
So nickel dependent
enzymes also are
responsible for removing a lot
of carbon monoxide and carbon
dioxide from the environment.
So microbes have
these enzymes that
allow them to use carbon
monoxide and carbon
dioxide as their carbon
source for metabolism.
And so collectively,
these microbes
are estimated to remove about
100 million tons of carbon
monoxide from the
environment every year
and produce about 1 trillion
kilograms of acetate
from greenhouse and
other gases, such as CO2.
So there's a lot of benefit to
us from these nickel enzymes.
And so people are
interested in doing
a couple different things.
One thing they're
interested in doing
is to see what
these nickel centers
look like so that they can
make small molecules to do
the same chemistry.
People are also interested in
taking these microbes as such
and getting them to
overexpress these enzymes
and then convert things
like CO2, greenhouse gas,
into biofuels.
So some people in
chemical engineering
are doing that right now, and
I'm collaborating with them
on some of these projects.
So this is, again, a very--
everyone is very concerned
about climate and so this
is a hot area of research.
So of course, if you want to
know what something looks like
at atomic level,
x-ray crystallography
is a great thing to do.
But if you don't have
a crystal structure
you can use spectroscopy.
In particular, you
can think about
whether the enzyme
and this nickel center
is paramagnetic or
diamagnetic, and that
can help you guess what the
geometry of the metal center
is.
So this is sort of
a first experiment
you might try to
do to understand
what's going on in your enzyme.
So say you have a nickel
plus 2 or d8 center
and it's found to
be diamagnetic.
Then we could be asked,
can you rule in or out
some of the common
geometries for nickel
based on this
single observation?
So let's do that.
So we want to add
some electrons.
So I'm going to go over
here, and I have our diagrams
on the board.
So first, octahedral
is a common geometry.
Does it matter if this has a
big splitting or small splitting
for a d8 center?
What do you think?
Think about it for a minute.
Let's try it and see.
So if we have a
small splitting we
would go-- we put in
our three electrons.
And again, this is a d8 system,
so we have eight electrons.
We put in our three
and now we have
to decide if we're
going to go up here
or if we're going to pair.
But let's pretend it's
a small splitting,
so we'll put an
electron up here.
Than we're done.
Now we have to pair, so we're
going to come back down here
to pair because we're going to
put them in the lowest energy
orbitals.
So we have five, six, seven,
eight, and we're done.
Now, if we said that
the splitting was big
we would have paired all
of these electrons first
and then put two electrons
singly at the upper level.
And that would have
given us actually
the exact same diagram.
So in this particular
case, it doesn't
matter whether there's a big
splitting or a small splitting.
You get the same
electron configuration.
So is this diamagnetic
or paramagnetic?
AUDIENCE: Paramagnetic.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Paramagnetic.
Which means what?
It means that you have
unpaired electrons.
So we have unpaired electrons
so it's paramagnetic.
So let's look at the
square planar system now.
So we have three orbitals
that are down in energy,
and because our square planar
system is in the xy plane
and it's on axis and we
have-- so our ligand's
on axis and our
ligands on axis point
toward the orbitals on axis.
So dx squared minus y squared
is really high in energy.
xy is a little bit
higher, and these guys
are down at the bottom.
So we don't really know
anything about where
we're going to put them
in, but let's just put them
in singly in these lower ones.
So we'll do one, two, three,
and then we'll pair them up.
Four, five, six.
And then we have two more,
so that's seven, eight.
And we definitely, unless
we absolutely have to,
don't want to put any
electrons in our dx squared
minus y squared.
That's way up in
energy, so we don't want
to do that unless we have to.
So is this paramagnetic
or diamagnetic?
AUDIENCE: Diamagnetic.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Diamagnetic.
So we have one
option here that is
consistent with
the spectroscopy.
Now let's look at tetrahedral.
Is tetrahedral--
what do you think?
Is it going to be
high spin or low spin?
High spin so we'll
have a small splitting,
and that is because in
the tetrahedral geometry
you have-- your
ligands are off axis,
so we have an opposite
of the octahedral system.
The orbitals that were higher
in energy, more destabilized,
are now lower.
But the ligands aren't
really pointing directly
toward any of the d orbitals,
so the splitting overall
is much smaller.
So this splitting is always
going to be pretty small,
and so that leads to
a high spin system,
which is you have the maximum
number of unpaired electrons.
So you can always assume
it's high spin or splitting
is small, so we're going
to put your electrons
in singly to the fullest extent
possible before you pair.
So we'll put one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight.
So is this diamagnetic
or paramagnetic?
AUDIENCE: Paramagnetic.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Paramagnetic.
So of these three
choices, the only one
that would be consistent
with the spectroscopy
is the square planar system, and
that turned out to be correct.
It was a square planar system.
And so here is a picture of
that square planar system.
So here we have the
nickel in the middle
and we have four ligands
all in one plane.
So we have this really
nice square planar geometry
that people predicted
would exist before there
was a crystal structure.
And so this is one of the
catalysts for allowing microbes
to live on carbon dioxide as
their carbon source, which
is really an incredible thing
that an organism can do.
Little microbes,
bacteria-- super cool.
They can do all
sorts of chemistry
that we struggle
to be able to do.